the troops are going to fight a lot
harder if they see the general on the
front lines
you want to associate with people who
are better than you are i mean basically
you'll go in the direction of the people
that you associate with
if you're going to be good at anything
you got to stay ahead of the game and
business is the ultimate sport wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life
and learn the billionaire algorithm that
will change
your future enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one rise above
challenges with oprah winfrey is there a
painful moment
in you all's life that actually ended up
being enlightening
the reason why that we were just talking
about this before you came in the reason
why
that thank you for bringing it to our
attention uh the reason why the wound
quote
is so profound is because
once you've been around as long as i
have you know that there is not
one single thing
that has ever happened to you or will
happen to you
that will be wasted if you look at every
single
crisis difficulty challenge every
joy-filled
moment that comes into your being
everything is there
showing up to make you more of who
you were meant to be and it's showing
there to how it's showing up there
to help you nothing ever is wasted
rule number two out learn everyone with
mark cuban
i gotta learn right because you know if
i'm gonna be an investor now right
it's not like i'm worried about my next
sale right to pay to get my 1500
commission but you know but if i'm going
to be the guy that
you know whether it's on shark tank or
we're doing deals
if i want to be a tech guy you got to
learn the tech i mean literally
i've got all these books around here i
mean just about
you know learning new technology
learning about ai
learning about you know um personalized
medicine
all these things so yeah i still will
read the manual
you know only now it's like a download
instead of a book
but um yeah because you got to because
if i'm going to be out there saying i'm
a tech guy and i don't know
about tech and i don't want to be that
guy i don't i'll pass that fake it to
you make it i want to be that
guy who really knows the stuff
everything i do is about learning more
because that's the only way i can kick
your ass you know it's not i'm not gonna
out athletic you right
it's not about my basketball iq it's
about my business iq right
in technology and business and
everything's always changing
if you know five years ago if someone
would ask me about artificial
intelligence i wouldn't know
right yet ai is the most important part
of technology and really business
going forward so if i'm gonna be an
effective investor an effective
mentor an effective you know um operator
of businesses
you know even with the maps i got to
understand ai because you know
like with the mavericks when you know
when you talk about analytics
it's changed so dramatically even over
the last five years
going from you know different types of
things per
and you know advanced rpm and all these
different
metrics for basketball to how do you
implement artificial intelligence and
pose estimation
and computer vision and how do you
understand all that stuff to make the
right decisions for the maps
and so if i want to be in a position to
make those decisions
and not just ask somebody else to do it
i got to learn it
and so i put in hours i do tutorials i
take little online classes
and it doesn't make me an expert it's
not like i'm going to say you know
i could get a job if i needed to running
ai or running
tech for a big company i couldn't but i
understand all the concepts and
understand the issues and how to apply
them to business
so if you're going to be good at
anything you got to stay ahead of the
game and business is the ultimate sport
rule number three get on the front line
with elon musk
there's a lot of talented people at
spacex and tesla
[Music]
and i think the morale is is good
i for sure respect them greatly and it's
an honor to work with them
and i find that if if i am um
and gross in the details of the issues
this does not result in them feeling
better but
worse but feeling better like they're in
my experience more energized
um you know it's like
you know you think about like war
it's like you want the general in some
like
you know ivory tower or or on the front
lines
like troops can the troops are going to
fight a lot harder
because if they see the general on the
front lines than if they think generals
you know in some cushy situation so
it's like
nobody bleeds the prince in the palace
get out there on the goddamn front line
and and you know show them that you care
and that
you're not just in some plush office
somewhere also if you want to have
more self-confidence and self-belief
i've created
a special free program called 254
because the sign says that it takes up
to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a habit
so what i'm going to do is send you an
unlisted video to your email
every day for 254 days for free
to help your confidence and self-belief
shift forward
the link to join is in the description
below but if you ask me to write a story
on what is
potomac electric power worth or
something like that i can write the
story and that's what i'm doing every
day i'm assigning myself a story and
then i go out and
so you get starting companies like
staring into your bus and
eating glass rule number four pick your
friends carefully with warren buffett
the most important thing uh
aside from the things i've talked about
already is is really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are i mean
basically you'll go in the direction of
the people that you associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes uh
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
and when obviously you can't pick your
parents
uh they're gonna have an enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices
as you go down the line and you who you
uh who you admire who you who who you
want to copy and the most important for
most people in terms of that decision is
their spouse
it's also important in terms of a
partner in business but the partner in
life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little that
better than you are and then he or she
and hopefully you hope they don't figure
it out too fast rule number five
manage your time better with jeff bezos
there are a lot of things that are a
waste of time
you know when you think about your life
i think i
i often tell people um that i work with
if you can get because people people
have very high standards for
how they want their work life to be and
uh and i said look if you can get your
work life
to be where you enjoy half of it that is
a home
that is amazing because very few people
ever achieve
that because the truth is everything
comes with overhead
that's reality everything comes with
pieces that you don't like
you could be a supreme court justice and
there's still going to be pieces of your
job you don't like
you can be a university professor and
it's still going to be
you have to go to committee meetings and
you have to do you know
there are every job comes with pieces
you don't like
and we need to say that's just how
that's
part of it and and not resent those
pieces or try not to
but also try to minimize them i tell
senior executives
you should have the least stress you
know there's this weird
i think false idea
that ceos i'm a ceo there's this false
idea that ceos are under the most stress
well i look at that i'm like why you're
in charge
why don't you delegate the stress it's
your choice
and so it's you have to figure out how
to
set up your life in such a way that you
can minimize the things
and i find people don't dislike hard
work
what people dislike and what is being
um out of control like they can't
control their life they can't control
their environment
this happens to me when i get over
scheduled
i hate being over scheduled i want some
time
to be able to think and free myself we
all have the same amount of time in the
world
nobody has more time than anybody else
and when you become a very successful
person
one of the things you start to get over
scheduled
you have this event you had to agree to
do this and maybe last night you were
like
why did i agree to do this i have to go
on stage tomorrow
i wish i were really with my family and
you know or i hope maybe not
this case let's say that you like this
one but in general
that kind of thing happens and so you
have to guard your time
and um and and try to say a little bit
flexible
so that's for me it's not a waste of
time
but i like to have some freedom of
movement
uh rather than having every minute of
every day
scheduled rule number six explore your
limits with larry ellison
i think we are we as human beings are
endlessly curious about ourselves
and we're cute and we love to test
ourselves constantly we
and we and we find all sorts of arenas
to test ourselves in
and you can tell you know uh right now i
have a racing sea sail the fastest
racing sailboat in the world maybe the
pat the fastest
racing sailboat in history uh sayonara
has
raced 26 times we have 24 firsts and two
seconds
and i'm discovering all sorts of things
about me as i race that boat uh i
discover all sorts about
all sorts of things about me every day
as oracle competes with microsoft for
supremacy in the software world
so there's a wonderful there's a
wonderful
saying that's dead wrong that says you
know why did you climb the mountain i
climbed the mountain because it was
there that is utter
nonsense ludicrous and absurd you
climbed the mountain
because you were there and you were
curious if you could do it
you wondered what it would be like uh
you wonder what the view was on from the
top
um and that's
how we explore the thing that we're most
interested in
interested in is exploring our own
limits
and exp uh and exploring our
relationship with others
we're much more interested in each other
and ourselves than we are everything
else
and rule number seven the last one
before very special bonus clip
is execute well with bernard arno i
think
almost as important as the idea at the
beginning
is the execution and the fact that
building on the id must be
really very professional very efficient
and that also makes a difference i have
seen a lot of startups
with very interesting ideas
but with also some other competitors
almost with the same ideas but only one
or two of them are successful it's
because
the execution of their
business plan so it's key for the
long-term success
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
there's an infectious feeling here that
innovation
can solve almost every problem
that's the belief that drove me in 1975
to leave a college in the suburbs of
boston
and go on an endless leave of absence
i believed that the magic of computers
and software
would empower people everywhere and make
the world
much much better it's been
40 years since then and 20 years since
melinda and i
were married we're both more optimistic
now than ever
if you want to know the five billionaire
habits that you must copy check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there by far the best
investment you can make is in yourself
i mean that for example communication
skills i tell the students that come
that they're going to graduate schools
and
business